you ever hear the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise welcome back everyone
is Charlie this is gonna be my full Star
Wars Episode nine rise of Skywalker
review video if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos there's a whole bunch
of Mandalorian stuff coming up too so
because this is meant to be my full
review I'll say it careful for spoilers
from Star Wars rise of Skywalker because
we'll be talking about everything every
aspect of the movie so it needs to be
said yes the movie does feel like a bit
of a hot mess highlight reel of a reddit
wishlist of Easter eggs and references
like they weren't quite sure how they
wanted to end things and JJ Abrams came
in really late they didn't have a lot of
time to finish the script so they said
what can we give fans that they will
hate the least like there are a number
of choices we can make based on what's
been set up in the trilogy so far we
need to answer all these questions what
are the choices that we can make that
people will hate the least so we'll do
that so even though there were a couple
things that I think worked really well I
think most of the issues with the film
come from the fact that it feels like a
Franken film that sort of cobbled
together based on movies that don't
really exist an unproduced remake of the
last Jedi that the Star Wars people feel
like fans wanted there a number of
character beets like say for Luke
Skywalker that directly contradict what
he was doing during last Jedi so it's
very clear that a lot of the things that
they did during rise of Skywalker are
meant to address things that they felt
people were upset about during last Jedi
in the fact that they brought Palpatine
back physically feels like a last minute
addition like that wasn't originally
part of their plans for the movie so
there are a couple of things that they
do with force lore and Sith Lord that
seemingly contradict the earlier films I
will address that stuff too the actors
do try to do their best with the
material but most of the time there
aren't any real conversations happening
between people because a lot of the
movie feels like a glorified fetch quest
like you would see in a video game like
a lot of you been playing fallen order
for the last couple of weeks it's a
great video game but that genre is meant
to be that way by design movies aren't
meant to be glorified fetch quests so a
lot of times when characters are talking
to each other the dialogue that they
have is
just there to set up something else
another character needs to say so they
can turn round have their big moment the
camera zooms in they say something
dramatic that then drives the characters
to the next step of their fetch quest so
the movie comes off a lot like a video
game in that way a video game with
amazing huge cutscenes like I said JJ
Abrams was pretty honest about the fact
that he was brought on really late in
the process and I think that contributed
to a lot of their development problems
originally Colin Trevorrow had a version
of the movie he was going to do he was
fired seemingly because the version of
the movie that he was going to do wasn't
something that they were really happy
about we'll never know fully what that
was going to be we've got little bits
and pieces of it
so Abrams was brought in to help them
make their release date otherwise I
think if there would have been any other
director they would have delayed the
movie for another year there are a lot
of things during the movie that do
contradict earlier parts of the can in
the earlier films I also just saw
recently that the Lucasfilm story group
that are sort of the keepers of the
Canon in help people and film makers
when they're making this stuff so that
it makes sense with the other stuff
that's come before were not involved
with the making of this movie so that
was not a big surprise remember that
moment during force awakens where Han
Solo says to Finn that's not the way the
force works so I feel like a lot of the
minor missteps could have been avoided
had they brought in at least a couple of
these people whose job it is to remember
everything in every detail about Star
Wars so that they don't wind up stepping
on the toes of the movies that have come
before really good example is at the end
of the film where Palpatine says I am
all of the Sith now wait a minute
all the force spirits live within you is
that a real thing that doesn't sound
like the way the force works
first off technically the ability to
become a force spirit is something that
only highly trained Jedi Masters can
learn it isn't something that every Jedi
gets to do I think there's a way to
explain kylo Ren or Ben solos ending at
the end of the film and why he becomes a
fourth spirit but I'll get into a lot of
those minor details and plot twists when
I do my top 10 WTF video because I feel
like a lot of Star Wars fans will be
scratching their heads in visible
confusion during various parts of the
film but while there is a lot of stuff
that you can nitpick in this movie a few
things that I think worked really well
or all the scenes with kylo Ren
andhraite together when they're just
doing either they're for Skype sessions
or they're fighting each other
physically having their lightsaber
battles or
just working through their emotions
together helping each other out right
teaming up together all that stuff
worked for me I know there are a lot of
questions about the ending specifically
because the last 20 or so minutes gets
really crazy but while the movie as a
whole feels like a rushed mess I feel
like JJ Abrams came in late in the game
like he said saw the script as it was
and then saw a couple things that were
already working really well like kylo
Ren and Rey's scenes that they shared
together and decided to focus most of
his attention on getting that stuff
right I liked all the force dyad stuff
I'll get technical about how that works
this weekend when I do more explainer
videos but they're meant to be two
halves of one force being which is why
they're connected across space the way
they are and why his spirit becomes part
of her at the end of the movie two
halves a one person being United inside
Rey becoming whole inside her so she
metaphorically and literally carries him
on with herself which I think by their
logic is also meant to kind of inform
why she chooses the Skywalker name at
the end of the film the other reason for
that I think also is meant to be because
she feels like Luke and Leia are the
parents that she never had even though
like I said this movie is based on a
sequel that didn't happen like they
don't clearly set any of that stuff up
during last Jedi they're the two main
leads of the whole trilogy though so it
makes sense the Abrams would want to at
least get their story and their scenes
right during the movie and I feel like
most of their stuff does work it's a lot
of the other stuff that I have issues
with some of their arc does feel like it
was made up on the fly post last Jedi
like Abrams always wanted redemption for
kylo Ren of sorts then giving him the
honorable death as a Jedi like Darth
Vader dying as Anakin Skywalker and
Return of the Jedi
remember JJ Abrams really likes to
repeat beats of the original trilogy I
was fine with the ending that they gave
that character Adam drivers performance
throughout this new trilogy has been
great and even though I don't think that
they originally planned on bringing
Emperor Palpatine back I do think there
was some loose plan to tie Ray's origin
to either Palpatine or someone really
evil and she was always going to have to
learn the lesson that where you come
from doesn't matter what matters is who
you choose to be all three of the new
films kind of feel like they're fighting
each other for dominance but I think the
overall message that they were trying to
go for with the new films is that it
doesn't matter if you
born into a legacy of evil you can
choose to be a good person you can
choose your family it doesn't matter
what family you were born into but
that's kind of where I think the newer
films fall down on a thematic level is
that they sort of lack the overall
cohesion that the George Lucas trilogies
have the fall and rise of Anakin
Skywalker I know there are a lot of
questions about how the ending of this
movie with Palpatine coming back and
raised seemingly defeating him for good
seemed to contradict some of Anakin
Skywalker story in the original movies
it does a little bit but I think that's
a product of their last-minute decision
to physically bring Palpatine back like
I said I think that they originally
intended for Rey to be tied to Palpatine
in some way in his Specter would loom
over the events of the new trilogy but I
don't think they meant to make it as
literal as they did originally I think
originally JJ Abrams plan was to make
Snoke the new emperor figure of the new
trilogy and in the third movie kylo Ren
still comes back to the light helps Rey
defeat him and then dies his honorable
Jedi death the powers that be at
Lucasfilm kind of wanted to give each
filmmaker because Colin Trevorrow
originally was gonna be directing the
third film so it was gonna be three
different directors for three different
new films in the trilogy and they wanted
to give them as much creative power as
they could over each of their own
individual movies so you wind up with
three very different films so I really
do feel like with Star Wars needs is
either a Kevin Feige like figure who's a
little more involved in what the story
is going to be having a better plan when
they start out or just letting one
person do each of the films in a new
trilogy which is why you may have heard
Lucasfilm is sort of backing off the
idea of trilogies for the next group of
films there'll always be more Star Wars
films but I think now they're gonna take
it one movie at a time and if one does
well they'll be open to doing a trilogy
with whatever those new characters end
up being despite some of the issues I
feel like some of the things that worked
really well during the film are the
music John Williams has always been
fantastic with what he does for each of
the movies he's on point during rise of
Skywalker
he even has a great cameo during the
film - I think some of the stuff that
they did with Leia work real well it's
pretty clear that they brought in
Harrison Ford at the last minute because
it was supposed to be Leia on the Death
Star that was bringing Ben's solo back
from kylo Ren the reason that he turned
back into Ben solo but because she
passed away they had to bring in
Harrison Ford like they call him up look
we really need this scene where he comes
back to the light and it needs
be one of his parents you're the only
one that's available can you please come
do this for a couple minutes
I've already talked about the stuff with
kylo Ren and Rey together Adam driver
being fantastic Daisy Ridley does what
she can with the script like I said the
script is one of the weak points of the
film when she and Adam driver are
together that's when she really shines
during the movie The Emperor's
performance is also great too even if
some of the scenes that they gave him in
the script contradict earlier parts of
the franchise talking about the very end
of the film specifically where she
buries the lightsabers on the large
moisture farm on Tatooine
I think this scene was more for the fans
than it was a logical choice for her
character like they wanted to say yes
technically there aren't any living
Skywalker's left but Ben's solos part
Skywalker and his life force now lives
on inside Rey and those original
characters are so important we want to
show how important they are by making
them so important to Rey that she
chooses to take their name and carry
their legacy forward
there's the Ben solo reason for picking
the Skywalker name that she has but also
I think the idea that the force ghost of
Luke and Leia show up at the end because
within the script at least whether or
not you believe it she felt like they
were the parents that she never had like
I said though they didn't really set
that up at all during last Jedi or even
during force awakens so it's a bit of a
head-scratcher moment like okay I think
I see what they were going for but it
doesn't quite land the way that it would
had they set it up properly so even
though people are sensationalizing a lot
of their reviews and the way they talk
about the film I feel like it's just
okay and that's it but breaking my
favorite Star Wars movies from favorite
to least favorite I'm just gonna include
twelve here the live-action stuff not
the animated Clone Wars movie we start
at the top with Empire Strikes Back then
a new hope Return of the Jedi
rogue one Revenge of the Sith force
awakens rise of Skywalker last Jedi
because it's a well made movie but
canonically just doesn't sit well with a
lot of fans then Attack of the Clones
Phantom Menace the holiday special and
then at the bottom is solo because the
holiday special was made knowing that
they were making something bad
intentionally just to sell toys it's
meant to be this big advertisement they
were trying to make some sort of
Shakespearean masterpiece but everyone
let me know what is your new ranking of
your favorite Star Wars Phil
after seeing brides of Skywalker you
don't have to rank them all together you
can just do the 9 saga films but what's
happening next is I will do a top 10 WTF
video in a video specifically for the
ending explaining some of the canonical
changes that they make there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs I'll be doing more
Mandalorian videos but if you have any
specific videos or big questions you
want me to answer in those videos just
let me know in the comments everyone
click here for my new video for the
Mandalorian set up in the finale and
then click here for my full Mandalorian
episode 7 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I have spoken
you